But you've never explained why you think that happened
except to say that the west fears a strong Russia,
but we have a strong China.
The west is not seem very afraid of.
Uh, what about Russia do you think
convinced policy makers they had to take it down?
The west is afraid of strong China
more than it fears a strong Russia
because Russia has 1
50 million people and China has 1.5 billion population
and its economy is growing by leaps and bounds
or 5% a year.
It used to be even more.
But that's enough for China.
As Bismarck once put it,
potentials are the most important.
China's potential is enormous.
It is the biggest economy in the world today
in terms of purchasing power parity
and the size of the economy it has
already overtaking the United States
quite a long time ago.
And it is growing at a rapid clip.
Let's not talk about who is afraid of whom.
Let's not reason in such terms.